there's just so many reasons why i'm
happy about this graphics card and
honestly people are just looking at this
the completely wrong way don't go
anywhere
all right so for like the six of you
that actually haven't seen any rx 6500
xt content already let me get you up to
speed extremely quickly before we talk
about why exactly i'm actually thrilled
about this gpu launch and i think you
should be as well humongous shout out by
the way to powercolor for sending over
this fighter card so sam could run the
benchmarks well ahead of this embargo
drop so amd announced this super trimmed
down budget gpu at ces a couple of weeks
ago and it's set to launch at an msrp of
200 bucks and we all know that clearly
is not gonna happen i'm honestly gonna
guess that this card is gonna be
purchasable for around 350-ish dollars
but i still like it so let's move on the
main thing that people are super upset
with is that amd really stripped out
some serious features to make this thing
as cheap as possible specifically
there's no 4k h.264 encoding h.265 hevc
encoding there's no av-1d coding and
it's also only using a 4x link of pcie
gem 4. we all already know this but once
again don't go anywhere with all these
possibly major disadvantages i already
know what most youtubers viewpoints are
going to be with this graphics card and
a lot of them have already voiced their
opinion that you definitely shouldn't
buy this gpu i couldn't disagree with
them anymore on that opinion but one
thing that i do think we can all agree
on is that you really should have
windows activated on all your gaming pcs
and gaming pc flips and good thing i got
the perfect sponsor for today's video
today's video is sponsored by icmmo.com
which is kindly hooking you guys up with
not just an activated version of windows
10 and removing that nasty watermark but
they're also giving you guys an
exclusive af 35 discount code if you use
zah-35 buying keys are super simple just
head on down to the links in the
description once you add that windows 10
key to your cart make sure you use the
discount code zh35 and that'll drop the
price down to less than 10 bucks there's
a ton of different ways to pay including
paypal and after buying you'll be able
to extract your key from there simply
press the start button on your desktop
type in activation paste in your key and
boom windows 10 is now activated and
you're good to go head on down to links
in the description and big thanks again
to icmmo.com for sponsoring today's
video okay so i think it's extremely
important to see the numbers and the
benchmarking data for this graphics card
before my possibly outrageous hot takes
on this new gpu so let's not wait any
longer and get rolling on that sam and i
did build a baller af new testing rig to
test out our gpus for this video and
we'll talk all about that build after
talking about the 6500 xt but an early
shadow to xpg is definitely needed for
hooking us up with a ton of these parts
so let's first start with a chart here
of the rx 6500 xt versus the slightly
more expensive rx 6600 currently the
6600 is easily one of the easiest brand
new graphics card that you can actually
buy right now and they're usually found
between 400 and 475 dollars and i
actually really like buying them
especially for people that want a new
graphics card and not deal with the used
market here you can see that the 6600 is
doing anywhere from 20 to 40 fps better
obviously depending on the title and
this is about the same performance that
i would expect from a car that costs 150
to 200 more real quickly while we are
here the 6500 xt can indeed play any
title we tested with at least 60 fps in
decent settings this isn't 1080p low or
anything like we usually do for budget
graphics cards so this is honestly
pretty solid results and slightly better
than what i personally expected you can
see here that only the first four lanes
are populated and i'm no expert in this
field but i do know that this could
possibly be an issue for people running
budget motherboards with pcie gen 3
slots and that's what most people are
worried about i'm 100 certain that every
other youtubers video is going to have a
ton of charts showing their benchmarks
between gen 3 and gem 4 slots and
honestly you probably already know the
answer to that question before watching
my video good thing that's not what my
video is about today now don't get me
wrong it's not a smart move that amd is
limiting a budget card like this
depending on which motherboard and cpu
you use but remember there's probably
going to be a single digit percentage of
people who actually buy this graphics
card using a motherboard and cpu combo
that supports pcie gem 4. instead most
people that are buying this card are
going to be using budget motherboards
and cpu combos using gen 3 and that's
what our benchmarks are going to be
based on for today's video so what does
all of this mean well what question have
we been asking for the last year of the
gpu shortage
did everybody forget other than just the
the prices going down of course what
have we all been asking for
we wanted budget graphics cards how many
times have we all rolled our eyes when
we see a new high-end 3080ti
ti or any other gpu launch that costs
over one thousand dollars it's been
pretty exhausting all we've been asking
for are budget graphics cards around the
two to four hundred dollar range and
this is exactly amd's attempt to fix
that now here's where all of my hot
takes are going to start and
specifically with the most important one
this here is a brand new new graphics
card this means that this card is going
to be sold at places like online
retailers physical stores like best buy
and micro center and probably even the
newegg shuffle we currently don't have
that option available for new budget
graphics cards right now and i don't
think people are understanding how
awesome this is there's so many people
out there that are trying to build a new
600 to 800 system and there's just not a
single solid option out there for them
right now if they don't want to deal
with the used market this 6500xc
although definitely limited in features
is exactly their solution so they can
finish their builds and jump into pc
gaming finally and knowing that this is
a budget graphics card this card is
meant to be purely for budget gamers
that want to finish their gaming pc
builds this card isn't meant for video
editors that are looking for future
proofed encoding options or anything
this is just a temporary solution so
people can finally start pc gaming on
something other than integrated graphics
don't get me wrong not having these
features can definitely affect some of
you but when you zoom out and think
about who exactly amd was targeting for
this graphics card launch i think it
mostly makes sense so they could keep
their costs down also going back to it
being a new card remember that this
means you'll have the ability to return
it file a troubleshooting ticket use
your warranty etc these are the features
that new builders are actually looking
for because it's much safer than taking
a gamble on the used market amd isn't
releasing this gpu to push new
technology or boast about crazy price to
performance it's simply to give the
desperate pc gaming market a new option
to buy at the lowest price point that we
have right now and i'm super happy that
they did now there are other graphics
cards to compare this one too the only
reason we used the 6600 was for
reference but now one that you should
definitely just completely remove out of
your head is the rtx 3050 which i don't
have in the studio unfortunately but
please don't even start to make that
comparison the rtx 3050 and rx
xd are in no way going to compete
against one another because we already
know that the 6500 xt is extremely
limited in features especially compared
to the suite of features that nvidia and
the rtx platform has but also there's no
way that the rtx 3050s price isn't going
to be all the way jacked up to like the
500 ish dollar range and these cards
just aren't gonna be on the same level
in terms of pricing at all now one card
that i think you should compare this
card to is the rx 580 but that's
specifically for pc flippers in mind
that are debating about buying a used
two to three hundred dollar 580 or the
now brand new 6500 xt here's our chart
showing our 6500 xd vs rx 580 benchmarks
and as you can see they are indeed
trading bows with each other depending
on the title but the 6500 xd is slightly
better on average don't get me wrong
this is a very harsh reminder that this
2022 release gpu is competing with a
card that came out all the way back in
2017 but remember the 6500 xt's purpose
isn't to have bleeding edge technology
or price to performance it's simply to
provide a brand new option for people to
buy around this two to four and a half
price point and around this 1080p medium
to high settings level of performance
also just as a reminder in case you're
skipping around this video this is
testing the 6500 xt and the rx 580 with
pcie gen 3. now one thing that i do want
to mention real quickly just to balance
things out a bit is to talk about these
ports i have never seen a graphics card
in the last five years launched with
only two outputs and that can definitely
be frustrating to some of you i'm not
sure if this is how most cards will be
or just this power color fighter but
either way if you were planning on
running a multi-monitor setup please be
sure to research this ahead of time
before buying now this video isn't over
yet but i want to hear you guys sound
off in the comments section after
hearing my opinions on the 6500 xt what
are you guys thinking and i know i got a
little bit heated there for a second but
let's try to relax and just stay a
little bit calm down there in the
comment section one thing that i think
we can actually agree on though is this
absolutely fire testing build that we
built today so we got to talk about
what's inside of it and real quickly we
are gonna be selling this build during
the next ctt website launch on february
1st and we'll be selling it with the
sapphire pulse rx 6600 in there for
anyone that's interested in that so like
i said huge shout out to xpg for
supplying a lot of these parts and i'm
actually super happy that they sent over
these because i wasn't too familiar with
some of these products and they were
awesome for our testing the case that
everything is inside of is the xpg
defender pro and this thing is somehow
both a tank and an absolute beauty i'm
in love with the front mesh design and
clean af all black aesthetic and you
guys know that i typically take
advantage of psu cutouts like this so i
can vinyl wrap the power supply but even
the aesthetic of the xpg core reactor
750 gold was on point as well this was a
perfect amount of juice for our testing
by the way and i don't comment too often
on the aesthetic of power supplies but
they nailed this one xpg also sent over
the gamex s71 terabyte nvme drive which
was an absolute monster as well we're
talking pcie 4.0 speeds of up to 7 400
over 6 800 which is obnoxiously fast
they also sent our ram kit today which
is the spectrex rgb d60g and we use the
two by eight gigabyte kit clocked at
3600 megahertz they did send out a 32
gigabyte kit but i wanted to keep it at
16 gigabytes to give a realistic testing
scenario for someone that would actually
be buying a 6500 xt same thing with the
cpu we tested today with the 5600g and
if you recall what i said earlier this
cpu doesn't support pcie gen4 and this
is honestly probably the highest end cpu
that anyone on the planet is going to be
pairing with a budget card like the 6500
xt remember that this build today isn't
a build guide that you should follow
because of this gen 3 and gen 4 solution
you could be leaving performance on the
table but instead it provides us with a
realistic testing environment using gen
3 speeds that you'll find on more budget
cpu motherboard combos cooling our cpu
though today by the way is the xpg
levante 240 aio which looks minimal and
clean af and kept their temperatures
very nice and chilly here's what the
final parts list is looking like with
everything else and once again i just
wanted to use something that was a bit
more realistic for people interested in
the cards that we tested today instead
of putting something like a 13 900k in
there once again please let me know what
you guys are thinking about the 6500xt
after hearing my opinions i'm super
excited to hear yours also feel free to
click the video that's on the screen now
if you want to find out my favorite
budget use graphics cards that you
should be buying right now but just like
always i hope you enjoyed this video